I love Street Fighter.
I love this game so much.
I love everybody.
For those who are wondering why it's Street Fighter...
It's Street Fighter Week!
Wow!
What's your rank?
Still flat one!
Oh, it's not looking so great, guys.
It's not looking so great.
Okay.
I found out you can lose Platt.
Okay, wait, wait.
We're going to get into a coaching session.
Chad's got to wait for me.
But two days ago, I found out you can lose Platt.
How did I find out you might wonder?
okay wait wait wait wait I'll show you guys I'll show you
guys the our discord messages of when I've discovered you
can lose plat alright here we go for those who are wondering
I have a street fight remember the new challenges tournament
last time we did like a year ago well I'm back at it again
but this time i'm not in baby tier anymore i'm in the tier
above baby tier and you know where emily was and then you
know how emily was definitely not having the best of time
that's me right now that's me this this tournament so i no
longer have baby privilege anymore so um you know when emily
was getting her shit kicked in with jb yeah that's gonna be
me soon That's gonna be...
Anyway.
So...
Yeah.
My tear...
Let's just say...
My tear was a little hard.
But...
My tear was a little hard for this new challengers
tournament.
And I'm not playing Honda.
I'm not playing Geef.
I'm playing My because I was like, I would like the most
degenerate character.
Because I need anything I can get, you know, basically.
Like, I don't know.
I'm up against Kony.
And I asked Kony to please be nice to me.
And he never replied.
I don't know if he read the message.
But I don't think he's going to be it.
I don't think he's gonna go easy on me.
I, I, I don't think there, I don't think anybody's gonna go
easy on me.
So, um, so everyone else is in Diamond right now.
Um, and I might just be hard stuck flat at the moment.
Um, so let's see if Sean can do anything today.
All right, all right, let's get in the call of Sean.
Yeah, I think he didn't even believe in me.
That's I would call him out.
He on the on the first coaching first and second coaching
session he did not believe even the dream.
He did not believe in the dream.
To be fair, I didn't either but you know you would think
like he would pretend to believe but he gave it to me
straight.
He was he was surprised I even got a win streak during my
second session.
so
okay let's get into the let's get into the call characters
with projectiles this is special hello oh she's here she's
here yeah so i was telling my chat how you didn't believe in
me during the first couple of sessions i i still don't what
do you mean what do you mean what do i mean i've never i've
never expressed this at all No, no, no, no, that's a lie.
I remember the second session.
You were like, I didn't even think I'd see a win streak.
I remember that quote.
I wrote that quote down so I could use it against you on
stream.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I remember that quote.
He was like, guys, he was like, oh my God, I didn't even
expect to see like a win streak too i what type of chat gpt
storyline did you write in and he was like let's count the
second session as our first session because our first
session was really rough i didn't think i had anything to
work with and you said that you were like i didn't think i
had anything to work with and
um i do vaguely remember saying the first see i told you i
told you i
anyway anyway we're getting there we're getting we made it
as a team effort yeah we made it we made it we got to plat
we got to play yeah you didn't expect to see plat did you
you didn't no i i expected to sleep flat eventually oh
eventually yeah so i didn't expect it when you you know when
you hit me up and say, oh, I'm hard stuck.
I need help.
And then 30 minutes.
It was a 30 minute 10 win streak.
I'm like, alright, cool.
Yeah.
And then he was just like, are you lying to me?
I was like, no.
And then I literally, you could see my history.
It was like, lost, lost, lost, win, win, lost, lost.
And then the moment I got a call of him, I went on a 10 game
win streak, got a plat.
I was literally hard stuck gold for so long.
I don't know.
very efficient yeah and now i'm hard stuck but and then he
saw me lose flat nah no you're you're setting up you're
literally you're setting up the story and then when i got
flat back i was like coaching session over i'm tired i got i
got that flat i didn't want to play anymore all right you
gotta you gotta we gotta lock in it's not it's not about the
rank look we we know feisty's just gonna carry us all the
way to the i might my all my hope all my hope lies on feisty
right now she can't do it alone you got it's okay i'll be
the cosmetic of the team i've accepted my i'll be cosmetic
i've accepted my fate oh my she's gonna need help she's
gonna need help It's okay.
It's a Karku can help.
Karku can help.
I mean, I would hope he helps too, but, you know, we got two
other members as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Kyle can help.
I'm pretty sure Kyle can help.
And I'll just be there.
I can be the, you know, the modest one.
You can always have one person that doesn't win their ones.
I don't.
As long as nobody else loses, we're fine.
that's I mean yeah sure like that that could work but also
like like like look I'll make it I'll still try make it look
like I'm trying I'm you're gonna make it look like it I mean
I am trying no I am trying I've been playing for two weeks I
played in Korea I played in Korea I'm gonna make you look
like I'm trying is a crazy look I'm trying my best but like
but Coney what we're gonna we're gonna cook Coney right now
we're gonna teach you how to cook Coney right now don't
worry about it I I believe in you smile and I always have he
said you did not you you do not believe all right i'm i'm
trying i did you not do you see my schedule i literally i
got mickey to coach me i'm getting that's how desperate yes
that's how desperate i am i literally reached out to mickey
i was like please go you know what he said you know wait let
me grab his let me grab the message which did not inspire
hope in me He was like, uh, it will be my biggest challenge
in my career.
There's no one to believe in me.
Honestly, honestly, valid.
I can't be the highest person you've ever, there's no way.
way i'm learning no you're you're doing a great job okay
thank you i think that's all i needed that's all all right
it's just that little bit of validation all right anyway all
right all right let me screen share real quick uh all right
stream street fighter six all right where where are we at
now the same place we left I did the sim thing I did the sim
thing the v rivals thing I got into masters and then I
googled how hard like is it accurate and people were like
the v rivals masters is literally gold slash plat level so I
was like oh well I thought I was really good just you should
have not you should have just lived in a little bit of
ignorance get that Yeah, yeah, I felt a little, you know, I
had a ego for a little while, but then I Googled it, and I
was like, oh, well, I guess, you know, wasn't as cool as I
thought I was.
Well, you know, so one, the whole reason why I told you to
do the V rivals was so you cannot worry about rank.
So then you start to worry about the V rivals rank instead.
Yeah, because I was like, I'm so cool.
I got to a mask.
I was like, oh my God, I'm speedrunning the mask.
I'm just maybe I am a master's player and then I found out V
rival's master is just it's just street fighter rankles okay
well do you remember the parts that I that I expressed were
important this all right well yes okay the cancels yes this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay okay there we go there we go yeah yeah it didn't come
now you gotta fix that make sure i implement it in the
natural game yeah well first off that's the hard part first
off let's make sure that it combos can you do the drive rush
overhead again all right yeah yeah yeah the drive rush oh oh
whoops
See, I did it.
See, I'm doing it.
I mean, it took a while, but I'm doing it.
All right, that's good.
Okay, we just got to hit that in a match.
I need to see that at least, just at least once.
Yeah, yeah, just that's the goal, right?
Just just once.
All right.
See, look, I did it again in the training scenario.
No, you didn't do it.
That one wasn't correct.
Look, I'm doing it.
There we go.
all right there you go there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right yeah you just need to hit that like once so okay
um again i'm gonna lose flat on stream probably but close
your eyes after every match is just close your eyes or
something guys i'm gonna lose just just just turn your head
away my tear i'm gonna be the only gold player my dear
conian brickier plat diamond now chad i i'm stalking them
i'm actually stalking them wait look
wait i need to show you wait not this i'm actually stalking
them you know i mean we have offline how do we get back
online wait okay is there a maintenance why any one of those
options you didn't have to go back to the title oh okay all
right i'm loading back in real quick also to my stream how
is shine's audio oh his maintenance over that's why oh it
was maintenance today yeah look wait where is the this is
important anyway no yeah look i'm stalking them look well i
mean there's other like platinums in there listen we can we
can fix this okay we can we can catch up i just we just need
you to lock in just a little bit no no you you can
stop stop scaring yourself just just just focus on what you
need to do okay okay okay i got this i
I believe.
All right.
But you need to believe in me too, though, for this to work.
I've never not believed you.
I don't know what you're talking about.
But we can, you know what I mean?
Like, listen, you made a lot of improvement.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
The past few days, you know, we can just do that.
If you just do that again at the same pace, we should be
Diamond, no?
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Hypothetically, that is true.
Yeah.
So just do that again.
again all right we can do this yeah i mean again if you just
implement some of those small little things your success
rate is going away okay hypothetically that should be like
theoretically that should work it it should yeah it should
work theoretically i mean listen if you just get used to the
stuff that i told you to do you know a little bit more
buttons a little bit more uh this that that's you don't
gotta panic it it's fine
there you go oh fuck yeah he did he did the di yeah yeah he
did i remember you do have when you're in burnout your super
has become way more um you know way more important so okay
nice Oh hey, okay, we we're doing the we're doing the super
cancel.
Oh my god Well, I didn't mean to do that.
I didn't mean to do that That's it's it's all right.
It's just the first game, you know, it's the It's the first
game.
So yeah, we got to warm up also.
I'm tired of listening to angry steam.
Okay Sorry.
It's not you.
It's me.
I forgot to mute my game audio.
All right Oh what the fuck
What the Oh i feel like i don't play against this guy enough
yeah i mean you don't you're not really gonna run into too
many gals at the moment um god nobody plays guys oh oh i'm
burnt out you are burnt out currently but oh you could have
you could have punished him there with the auto auto plus
circle also for context you guys are gonna hear me say that
doki specifically requests that i that i tell hurt how to do
things in button input oh no don't worry they know they know
okay all right just just making sure we're all on the same
page they know it's it's a pattern of mine it's right they
know it's it's been consistent all right just just making
sure we're all on the same page here good job though
oh so when when he does the ex fireball you have to be
careful because your ex fireball only has one hit
technically while their ex fireball has two this is a common
rule um well i would disagree but oh my gosh oh hey so i'm
i'm burnt out again yeah so that is another the other thing
we probably have to work on is try to burn out a little bit
less let's assist a little bit less remember if you're about
to burn out just back up and let it restore and then you can
throw your ex fan again
nice oh i thought i could break it yeah
we gotta yeah we gotta we gotta get down the counter counter
di's that would have that would have done you there so there
it's especially important to not burn out because If you are
familiar with the mechanics of this game, when you are in
burnout, you can now die from chip damage.
So it's okay.
It's just first match.
I'm just getting warmed up, you know, I'm just getting...
Surely.
Yeah.
I'm just getting warmed up.
All right.
Well, you'll figure it out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just not in my head right now.
But like, after my head grasps the concept.
i mean hopefully it's it's grasped it already we're good to
go i just need to warm up
oh oh okay a little tray combo oh you missed it but it's
fine yeah you're you are very dangerously close to burning
yeah i i'm burnt out
um i mean that's not entirely your your fault there but um
what we do need to control is how you react to the eyes that
is going to be pretty important yeah
oh i wanted to anti-air but then i'm i'm not warmed up
enough to be on the right side we gotta learn how to play on
both sides you know i i am learning Oh, what?
I swear to God.
Oh.
Oh, hold on.
You guys are playing.
You guys are playing newch.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
My.
My dog is.
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, nice.
Nice jump.
Where are you?
I see.
I'm good.
There you go.
I'm warming up.
He's warming up.
She's warming up.
We're good.
On those you don't want to do the cancel thing.
Wait, what's the cancel thing?
You just don't want to do like that into fireball.
You want to do the whole auto combo if you have a punish
there.
Yeah, on that sweep you did that in a fireball.
Oh my god.
oh my god fuck he jumped
it's okay i know that skills yeah yeah yeah yeah i burnt out
on purpose i surely yeah yeah i don't want to fight him
again you got it you could you know you could have like no
no it's okay It's you could have like learned a little bit
more, you know, I did I did I did learn I did learn Okay,
I'm learning
All right, nice.
Oh, I fucked up
It's okay.
We both fucked up It's okay.
We both fucked up.
Oh, it's okay.
I fucked up.
Oh, man.
Oh.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
See, see, it's okay.
What the fuck?
I've never seen that move before in my life so that is that
is back heavy punch um that he does he can like charge it
i'm sorry not back heavy but just stand heavy punch um he
can just you know charge it it has a little bit of a
different effect oh what when he charges it yeah oh there
you go nice um you did burn out again but it's it's it's
fine oh what the yeah you're a little bit far away Oh,
whoops, I might have grind.
I might have, if I mash that.
Oh.
Yay!
All right, solid.
You want me to fight him again?
You should fight him again, actually.
All right, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, no, he's adapting.
oh you almost got it again oh i thought yeah yeah be careful
yeah so you have to be careful pressing the auto combo too
much because obviously it'll cancel into stuff that's unsafe
so just be careful with that okay one thing we're gonna have
to introduce you to a little bit is the parry system of this
game yeah those fireballs you you do want to parry those so
that you at least drive gauge look i did it i did it we're
doing it we're doing it i did it she she found her di button
for once i did it okay i i don't have i don't have i'm burnt
out yeah you're burnt out again but you should uh you can
just block here a little bit is fine
yeah he's just letting you get your drive gauge back it's
gonna come back soon and then once it does you can you know
oh my god okay oh my god i'm i was not careful yeah you
weren't very careful oh you remembered hold on you're
remembering things yeah oh she's remembering to do wake up
super oh she's clutch she's clutch she's clutch i'm sorry
she's clutch 10 10 win trees coming right up We're already
at two.
Don't don't don't no no no no no.
What the fuck did I do?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, please stop.
Please stop.
Oh, I think she blocks it.
Yeah.
I think he blocked it.
Can you check the chat real quick?
What?
Wait, what?
Oh no, did I get in trouble?
Oh, whoops.
I don't even remember when I said anything.
It's like second nature.
It was a lie.
I don't remember.
Okay.
No.
look look i'm burning out look i'm burning out i'm burning
well you shouldn't be excited about burning out but you're
doing great oh i i did not mean to do that i actually i'm i
might have messed up i might have messed up i might have
messed up yeah you might be dead if he plays your card oh
you gotta you gotta block that high yeah he's doing like he
was doing us you threw me off with the check discord i what
do you mean you threw me off i didn't throw you off you
technically threw yourself off it's time it's time to take
it's time to take accountability now i have to be focused on
more than one thing i mean that's that's that street fighter
you know sometimes you'll be distracted by other other
things you know no yeah no sometimes you know i don't know
maybe maybe your your dog will may be barking in the
background no he will not be i'm gonna burn out it's okay it
was on purpose it was all right so basically i'm they said i
was cursing a little too much guys but like i don't even
remember when that happen i don't even remember i was two in
the moment you know the street fighter is a stressful game
you know it is oh my god i did not want to be oh my god i
did not mean to burn out there i did that yeah i mean we'll
we'll work on the burnout part it's it's it's not easy
because uh your your auto your auto combo spends meter so
it's you know okay your auto heavy spends meter too oh my
god he burnt out too though oh my god i'm dead anyway well
you're not dead you're perfectly fine he's in burnout and
you have full meter again so wait what do i do what do i do
you do the same thing you're always doing just you know
chucky expanding it you know easy um okay oh my god no okay
um oh he blocked it he blocked it too okay well i i will say
that was like three things i told you to do which is a plus
in and of itself i'll take silver linings you know you'll
get used to when to profit she did the thing she did the
thing i did the thing oh oh but then he did that thing yeah
you don't you don't know how long i've been trying to get
her dry rush overhead and have it work in a match and it's
been a couple days now yeah it's been a couple of days in
the works we finally got it we did it we did it i'm getting
my ass beat but we did it yeah i mean you can i'm getting
you know you can you can still you can still win this is
fine oh look at the secrets oh you could have done heavy you
could have done heavy heavy would have
That was good though.
I'm sorry.
You're fine.
I'm so sorry.
I was too passionate.
I mean, you did the thing.
and you'd use a di too it was looking good yeah yeah yeah
that was i think that was a great sequence if if that's the
one that gets us canceled from here then you know it was it
was a good way it was passion it was passion i'm just so
passionate about street fighting i'm just i love this game
so much
That was good though.
I mean, unironically, that was good.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That was the whole sequence.
You kind of put everything together there.
You know, you did the overhead thing.
I did this.
That you always told me to do.
And then you de-eyed him when he was in the quarter and you
had burnout.
You got the stun and you did the combo.
I was the first time I've ever stunned someone and I saw it.
I was so happy.
And then I fucked it up.
Oh, go on.
I love Street Fighter.
so much I don't understand we're doing it we're so we're
having so much fun I did not teach her this by the way I did
not teach her this he taught me this he told me to be
passionate and I'm just and it messed me up all right
oh my god oh my god no oh i'm stunned oh no oh no i'm just
i'm not in the moment right now i am not in the moment yeah
i mean you know just just lock in but don't don't lock in
too much what okay
Oh, what the?
I don't even know what she did there.
Yeah, her DP goes a little far forward.
You gotta be careful of that.
Just make sure that when you knock this guy down, he's going
to do wake-up EXDP a lot.
So what I want you to do, when you do knock him down, is I
want you to block on their wake-up and just let them fly in
the air and afterwards you do auto-heavy.
I...
so so i did not listen i'm sorry okay it's it's it's fine
i'm sorry of course okay we repeat that we repeat that i'm
listening now block block block block this block okay yeah
that'll punish yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah see i told you
i'm listening i'm listening i'm listening i i burnt out i
was not paying attention i was so happy that i got it okay
all right that was good okay yeah there you go yeah so you
see how he did that wake up move non-stop you know he's got
a block you block and then you just punish okay
oh no he's using he's using some dry rush oh my god
oh he jumped over me and i'll jump over you
oh she's doing the thing she's doing the things yeah
I'm very surprised actually.
Well, not surprised in the way that I thought you were
incapable.
But I'm...
No, no, it's not that I'm just saying, you know what I mean?
Like it's, you know, like you're catching on quickly.
You know, you're learning pretty fast when you are...
Oh, I thought I would break it.
When you put more attention into actually trying to do the
things that I mentioned, you're actually pretty good at
doing them in a reasonable amount of time.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Don't lock in that much.
No!
Um.
Oh, I was trying to triangle circle and I did everything but
that.
After this, I want you to just pause for a second.
Whoa.
Okay, goodbye for me.
Look, I got it.
I got it.
That's good.
Just make sure after this, I want you to just cancel the
queue for a second.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where am I?
oh well you could have punished that but okay at least i
don't know how what i could have done i just yeah i mean
yeah it's it's it's fine i didn't expect you to maybe like
an auto medium there would have would have punished that uh
the old tarik combo she did it's fine
okay nice all right you missed the little media a little bit
that's fine good antire okay we we have to work on i burned
out i burned out i burned out burned out we still gotta work
on the counter di's i burnt out okay
oh please get away from me punish that there you go all
right easy yeah you should plateau
that means i'm sort of around plateau level okay if you
think about it all right quick Quit writing back for a
second.
Okay.
Press go into training mode.
We're in training mode.
Press start.
Okay.
Because the one thing that we the one thing that we still
can't seem to get yet is UDI.
I try.
I don't want you.
I'm trying.
I don't.
This I tried it.
I tried it, but it's not it's not working.
You got you got to practice it more.
That's how this works.
You know, like, just...
The same way, the same way you practice everything else,
sometimes you gotta practice this, you know?
Like, you gotta sit down and practice some counter di's.
Yeah, I'm serious.
You just have to do this.
Actually, you know what?
Even better?
Alright, I'll make this a little bit more difficult.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna invite you to a lobby instead.
You're just gonna beat my ass!
Well, we're not playing.
Well, okay.
So we're not playing each other.
First of all, we're going into online training mode.
Okay, okay.
Jeez, all right.
All right.
Let me turn my audio back on.
Wait, is that the curse word?
That's just the butt.
I don't know.
I'm sorry, you're gonna beat my butt, I guess.
You're gonna...
I need a list.
You need a list?
I need a list, I don't know.
It's so... it's such a strong part of my vocabulary.
I mean...
Wait, what's here?
What's here in CFN again?
It's... now it's different.
It's not... not...
Oh my, doki-mai, doki-mai.
Is that all one word?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
All right, there you go.
All right.
Okay.
All right, return to mode select.
So what we're going to do, instead is yeah I am just going
to go into training mode okay and I'm going to do I'm going
to do two things okay I'm either going to jump at you or I'm
going to DI at random points and you need to figure out how
to counter both because we can't seem to get the DI down and
that's like one of the big parts I think is missing that
would help you a lot you know okay let's see
okay i did it i did it i get back up that's one all right
well you gotta move around so so the idea so the idea is
like you want to you want to like move around as if you were
playing an actual match because like for the most part
you're not going to be standing still like this waiting for
someone to do something otherwise you're going to get hit by
other stuff right yeah so nice okay
Oh.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm doing it.
Sorry, my button glitched.
It's not cursing.
Okay.
Oh.
Hmm.
That's not...
Throwing a little wrench in there.
That's not what you said you were gonna do.
Okay, I was hoping it would distract you a little bit from
the incoming DI.
Oh, whoops.
Oh yeah, your thing's glitched too, I see.
Yeah, my stick is a little bug.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, nice.
yeah so after you do that so you should just do like the
auto the auto heavy combo right or or auto medium depending
on depending on the situation if you don't have uh if you
don't have the uh meter and sometimes auto or if you want
the level one then auto uh auto medium is better or auto
plus x for you you know oh oh oh we're ready it's because
you're your think also jumps so it's
You missed two in a row.
Alright, there you go.
There you go.
I broke the streak.
Okay.
We're remembering where the button is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's it.
I did the karma.
Oh.
Okay, you did the dash.
Ah!
Oh.
Hmm.
That's not good.
the fuck i'm i stopped myself i stopped myself i stopped
myself i stopped myself
yeah you see so like yeah what's happening here is that like
you're just i'm giving you some other stuff to focus on so
in an actual match you're worried about all this other stuff
so it's kind of hard for you to react to di of course right
so the reason why i tell you to do like the drills matter
how easy they are they just get in the muscle memory get you
in the muscle memory of pressing it anyway regardless so
like as soon as you hear it it's more so a reflex for you to
just automatically press that button right okay um so that's
ultimately what you want to get that point to so it doesn't
matter how like easy the the particular drill feels you
should still do it anyway so that becomes a muscle memory
you know what i mean yeah
force her on so i mean it really the side here doesn't
really matter but we should switch sides anyway just because
it's like modern oh hold on i thought because it was modern
inputs it wouldn't matter but i guess forward dp does matter
but you can still do that though yeah you're fine no it
matters so much yes see it matters so much oh my god forgot
where my controls were oh man okay yeah I win the coin flip.
No, I win the coin flip.
I win the coin flip.
You can't always bank on the coin flip.
Yes, I can.
The buttons should still be the same though.
Like these di's, you should, you know, you can, you can get
those.
We got that.
Let it go.
All right.
Okay.
Oh.
Like, I did it.
I hit you.
We need a couple more of these, though.
There you go.
All right.
Look, I'm doing it on the left side.
Let me out of the corner a little bit.
Let me...
I don't know what she's doing.
I was doing over there, but...
I was getting you out of the corner.
Yeah, anyway.
Nice, okay.
i almost swore but i didn't do it yeah well you didn't do
what you were supposed to though that was almost five in a
row that i was counting i didn't make anyone angry oh there
you go okay i was family friendly on stream though and
that's more important i mean in this case yeah probably
that's more important all right so those are things you
should probably practice i think also you should spend some
time doing that drill anyway in in um in training room um
maybe what we should do is we should teach you how to set
this up so you can practice on your own time so um leave
this i'm gonna i'm gonna bring your your stream back okay um
so leave this here or yeah leave the training yeah there you
go to training room okay
Okay.
I'm going in.
I didn't set.
Okay.
All right, they go.
All right.
So what I want you to do, press start, go to recording
settings.
Okay.
there you go um go to record okay actually what i want you
to do um so switch characters get rid of ryu how do i get
rid of him oh basically you're right there oh okay well that
works too it's fine same same as all so yeah pick my pick a
different character let's uh let's use um let's use one of
the characters you're playing again so like was it going to
be alex or alex or chunny okay let's use any one of those
those three okay so um what you're gonna go here is go back
to that same screen go to uh recording settings okay go
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna use roughly like four
anywhere from like four to six of these okay um so slot one
i want you to once you hit start walking around back and
forth as if you were playing the game right as if you were
playing a normal match walk back and forth and then at a
random time whenever you feel like it just di okay so that's
still going to be the first recording so okay sorry press
start okay now you're going to use slot two and do the same
thing but at a different time so as you see that says like
423 f
press start again you roughly did it around the same timing
so maybe maybe so those are fine leave those recordings
where they are yeah leave those recordings where they are
it's just muscle memory you know it's just yeah i i was
watching and i knew and i knew you were gonna end up like
pressing it the same exact time anyway i just i just have
the muscle memory it's fine this one we're gonna make sure
you do this one a little bit sooner so this one's gonna be
sooner same You just gotta do a little bit sooner.
All right.
Just a little sooner.
There we go.
Press start again.
We're gonna redo that.
That's, oh, okay.
We're gonna redo that one because you're like, dashed in.
Oh.
That's fine.
Press start.
That's soon.
That's even sooner than sooner.
Yeah, yeah.
That's very soon.
But that's the idea.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're gonna want one of those.
So do it again.
Another recording.
Would you want me sooner?
I'm doing long.
now, along.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
You just want some variants between them.
This is a little, you have some interesting timings, but I
don't, the idea is just having some variants between them.
So this one in particular, maybe we're gonna do be a little
bit tricky with this one.
So like, what I want you to do, at least one of these slots,
I want you to wait a little of doing like uh instead of
doing di here what i want you to just press is like square
or something square or yeah or yeah
um maybe walk around the screen just a little bit more i
mean oh you want me to redo that yeah just redo that one i
mean uh okay redo it again because you dashed that's that's
gonna be a huge tell like stop dashing
walking all right there you go all right leave it leave it
leave it where it is okay oh hey 500 yeah all right maybe
maybe just one more we're gonna use six slots here okay
another one this one is just gonna di you don't have to do
the square or anything just di again same as you were just
choose a random timing that okay you're okay that was random
yeah it's fine it's fine it's perfectly fine okay we're done
with the recordings thank god um so we can go to replay
instead okay okay so you see how all these are on yes okay
what i want you to do is that replay info display setting at
the bottom yeah i want you to uh go over not it's not turn
it off but there's another setting here uh this off move the
setting over yeah yeah you don't want that on is what i'm
getting at yeah so that's perfect disable only for random
playback is perfect that's the one you on.
And always repeat playback.
So when you start this replay, the reason why I had you turn
that off is because if that's on, it will show you what slot
is playing.
So you know exactly what they're going to do based on the
timing of the information it gives you at the top left.
It'll show you in green.
But with that off, it now will not show you that.
So when you start this replay, typically what Viper is
pretty much going to do or what the game is going to do is
choose any one these six replays and play it back to you but
randomly so you don't know which one is going to play okay
you don't know when they're going to di and just to add a
little bit of a tricky effect in there um one of them is
going to be you know a little bit of a whip jab maybe like a
little bit of a faint right yeah so when you're on your own
you can practice so just start replay just so you can see it
in action okay is it yeah just like that there you go oh
what the thank you for stopping there okay um what that was
that was a driver verse so i think it was just it just ended
up being the timing there that's like my ai game sentience
like what happened there oh my god she just started thinking
on her own oh this hit me
so you just want to do this mainly to just get the muscle
memory of di's and an actual match is going to be much
harder clearly because there's good they're going to give
you a lot of other stuff to work to worry about and but once
you get used to this a little bit more we can work on
another drill that incorporates some jumps in here too okay
actually even better we could just do that press start okay
so um you can pretty much do anything you want with these
with these replays right so go back to over forward for just
for the sake of example um or it'll probably help you anyway
yeah um when you do this one the same way as when you walk
back and forth with the di what i want you to do is do jump
forward heavy or something the same way you do your jumpins
so like pretend as if you were the person jumping in like if
you wanted to hit the person in front of you right with a
jump in do that but while you're doing the recording to you
know my okay so do that under like slot seven so we're going
to use slot seven for that yep perfect all right just like
that that that's that's good enough um and another yeah
we'll just use the last one why not yippee uh restart this
one again you dash at the start yeah you don't want it to
record like easy visual tells like that because then like
there's no point of getting rid of it you'll you'll catch on
when you see the replays and the places anyway um go to
replay again yeah so start this so now those last two slots
now jumps will be in there too you know just to make it a
little bit more difficult for yourself and you want to try
and stop all of them okay oh
my god i can't dodge this it's a little difficult isn't it
yeah so um let me let me show you another really cool thing
about this too um so leave leave training character select
real quick all right so go go back to character select so I
do want you to still practice this and as you uh you know as
you go along yeah you know uh or maybe when you're queued up
for like ranked or something you can set her to do that
while you're waiting for matches ah what I want you to do
yes it's very useful to do that like in between games while
you're waiting you know so pick my of course like you know
pick pick whatever character but what i want you to show you
here is go back to ryu it's
okay so press start and go to recording so you see how the
training options are different depending on the character
yeah if you go back to viper it will have all of those
recording options saved specifically to viper and this this
feature carries over to reversal settings so reversal
settings that you set for ryu whether it be to do on wake up
or block whatever those are specific to those characters so
if you go back to viper all of your settings will still be
there so those are already set so on your own free time when
you are diligently practicing and studying street fighter to
prepare to help your teammates in the new challengers
tournament you will have those settings available to you to
practice you know i'll be a really good
that's that's not good what do you mean i can do both you
can be a good teammate and a good cheerleader a good
teammate is a teammate that wins i said i could do both okay
maybe you can you if you can do both win and be a great
cheerleader that is ideal actually yeah but if that doesn't
happen
not i tried my best it's not gonna happen if you lock in and
you do the drills i'm so locked in i swear i'm so locked in
you saw me get that 10 game win streak that was long was i
not locked in during those 10 that 10 game realistically
realistically no one saw it exactly exactly i
no one saw it yeah it may or may not have happened and no
one knows wait no i have the history do you yeah i don't
think you have the history no no no i do all right can you
go back to viper please no way no you no you no it's like
it's like in replays where's replays i know it's in
look it's like okay we don't look at all the losses wait no
this I don't see right here it's right here it's literally
wait no this is where we we had a little oopsie here this no
it's god wait no it's right here it's right here see it's
just right here one two three four five six seven eight nine
and then this is where I lost it it's right here um I mean
it's not 10 though that's 9 you count 9 it's still right
there i'm gonna fall i'm gonna favorite all of this so it's
here forever i mean you could favorite any assort of matches
of ones that you win and i'll show up in your replays as the
ones that you won you know like you could make a fake can
you go back to training mode okay okay i'll go back to
training that's on you you said it wasn't real
yeah that was a bait i told you to go back to train but i
didn't bait you into going no no you said my wins weren't
real because no one saw it but now i have odd proof so not
everyone saw it even capcon saw it i mean i don't i mean
sure i guess yeah i'm i'm here in training selected reu i
need you to i need you to pick yeah yeah i need to pick my
burger that's that's where your important training is yeah
there
you go all right here you go oh
and then see she's doing it there you go all right
hmm oh this is i forgot how long your replay are but it's
not it's not a bad thing it's it's good yeah it's good that
there's yeah every time i think i think that's one of the
fast replays playing while she's knocked down so then she
ends up doing a wake-up dry reversal i think that's just
what's happening there every time surprises me you miss that
one there you go got that Oh,
where's she gonna slap me?
All right, do you wanna learn a new combo to do off of this
real quick?
Sure.
Okay, so when you do this, I wonder if you can do, wait,
what's your, oh, down plus special, so a down plus triangle,
okay.
Okay.
What you could do here instead, if you want a little bit of
extra damage, is you could do, auto medium auto so so yeah
up until she does the spin okay and then you can do down
plus special after that spin instead of it continuing into
so so pause this pause this replay for a second i'll just
i'll just show you this yeah so so turn all of these off so
just go go by them and you know click the little box on on
the left that says on you know the left little box on the
left of all the recordings of this little boxes that say the
multiple boxes that say on right there you just went over
them okay to left right there okay turn turn those off i
don't turn it off pressed i think it's triangle for you
it'll be triangle oh there you go okay we're doing it all
right okay so if you press auto circle okay i'm sorry i'm
sorry auto auto plus x auto okay Okay, do it up until she
does the EX, the flames, that, that, yeah, yeah.
So after that, what I want you to do instead, is instead of
continuing the auto combo after that, do down plus special.
Okay.
Easy enough.
And then after that, cancel into level three.
So do down plus triangle plus circle.
uh you waited way too long okay remember when i said when it
hits when when she does the elbow there that you press it
then yeah you want that's what you want so you want wait i
do circle again or just i do the auto combo wait you do you
do you do use the auto combo up to the flame spin yeah yeah
you do you do everything you just did but you do down plus
triangle plus circle at the end that but you're doing it too
late so do it faster yeah to do it faster because you want
to cancel it into that yeah
she gets up too slow does that not work but you this might
be one of those things you have to delay it yeah never mind
this is this is this is one of those i forgot this is one of
those weird things you you it's because modern only uses the
light version
yeah yeah so so just do it normally just do down plus
triangle you'll see what i mean yeah just do down plus
triangle and and try to cancel it or maybe you maybe you are
just doing it too slow i can't tell i'm like yeah you are
you are doing it too slow no you're as as okay as soon as
you do down plus down plus triangle just start mashing down
plus triangle plus down plus triangle plus circle you're
doing auto and heavy by the way oh yeah you're doing auto
you want me to do the that you told don't i said do you want
me to do the auto circle combo i said auto circle combo and
you're like yes that's like oh i gave you the buttons you
asked for the buttons i said auto circle i said auto circle
so i was doing the auto circle combo you got me sounding
crazy saying triangle and circle for no reason no no and i
was like auto circle you're like yes so it's like another
combo and you're like yes i was like oh all right can you
try this combo again see look there you go there you go now
i now i get it i get it now see i get it All right, so we
can sometimes do that combo now when you hit a, you know,
when you, oh, you're still doing it.
Yeah, when you actually hit a counter DI, we can, we have a
little bit more of a combo you can do.
She's got a ton of other stuff she can do, but, you know,
maybe we can, we can figure that out.
Okay.
All right.
So set, so set her back to doing the, the drill again now.
Putting, putting, putting, putting it all together.
a little bit so when when she when she does di and you
counter it just do do that combo oh
all right easy enough right yay easy in the training room no
no it'll be it'll be easy in the training room you just the
hardest part about this is is that you just got to counter
the di that's it we got we got to get you in the habit of
just all right
look i'm doing it i'm doing the combo yeah it's easy enough
right yeah is she ever going to have free three bars
honestly fair point that's so true
all right there you go all right easy enough right yay all
right so uh all right maybe maybe you can play another one
but um uh you think i'm ready you think i mean i hope i hope
do you think i'm honestly that that part i'm not as worried
about compared to your insane levels of passion that's the
part i'm more concerned about right now
are you ready to see a burnout i mean it doesn't matter
whether i'm ready or not unless unless you want to surprise
me thank you thank you oh
my god stop freak
oh oh there's one you missed it yeah you missed it i sure
did we're not here to even win we're here to counter those.
I need you to hyper focus on those.
Okay.
The anti-Aras are great, though.
We got those.
Those are great.
It's okay.
Oh, what?
I wasn't trying to dash.
But I... Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so messed up right now.
Oh, this is a huge punish for you.
Is it though?
Oh my god.
Yeah, no, it is.
It is.
What are you doing?
Oh, I didn't know.
I tried.
I need you to know I did try to press it.
I was just too slow.
I mean, we'll get one eventually at home.
Oh, I did not mean to do that, but that's fine.
That's all right.
where you know maybe we'll we'll hit burnout now we we had
too much meter anyway not yet not yet
now um okay
oh oh i did not expect that yeah yeah so he's got a little
command grab he does there but he's not like invincible or
anything you can you can hit him out of it Or just jump.
When you see that, yeah, just jump.
Okay.
Nice.
Another one!
Oh.
No!
Oh, my god.
Yeah, when he does that little heavy, just jump.
Okay, cool.
I brought this combo.
But, um, yeah, it's fine.
So when you see him do like that that little double kick
thing he does if you're already crouching the second hit
will go under you So yeah like that so you can press a
button actually So for you you would press auto plus square
auto plus X auto plus square And yeah, and those will hit
him while he's still like doing the second kick over your
body You know because if you're crouching that second kick
will will it won't hit you What oh my he's He really wants
to kill me.
Sorry.
Oh, my God.
Um.
I know I could have done the thing that you love.
That you want me to do.
The one thing we're trying to practice.
Yeah, it would be ideal if you hit that thing while you're
trying to play.
You know, it happens.
It'll take some time to get used to, you know.
Yeah.
That's just what it is.
It'll take some time.
But at least.
you are further recognizing that you're missing it and it's
a missed opportunity so you can try to really focus on it
and get it next time just does it so fast oops yeah you get
used to it oh you got to press a sooner than that yeah press
sooner than that you'll get it but yeah oh i thought you was
gonna do it nope okay so if you think he's gonna do that
then some you gotta like just wait for it and then react to
it you know oh my god I don't know why I did that.
Nice antire.
The antires are looking great, though.
You know, you just got to do the same thing you did with the
antires with the eyes, and we are in business.
He keeps blocking it.
How does he know?
Nice.
Oh, we got the dry run.
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
Thank you for...
Thank you for raining.
one in i just i just felt the energy the passionate energy
on that one yeah yeah yeah yeah that's great i'm glad you're
excited i'm happy for you thank you me too i'm very happy
for myself oh my gosh did not mean to do that i wanted to do
this circle there you go yeah that yeah i wanted to do that
oh you're so I didn't say it I didn't say anything no you're
good oh my god honestly this is this was supposed to be like
you know Street Fighter coaching but I'm glad we got some we
got some solid PR coaching in there you know oh now he
doesn't do any He
grabs me!
That's right.
Nice.
Good job.
Aww, I should have known he was going to do that.
Hi.
Oh, good.
You found the good button.
You found the loop.
I found the loop.
Oh, interesting choice.
Nice.
Dude, that's good.
Oh my god.
Wait, do I have a level three?
I don't.
You don't, you don't have level three yet.
It's fine though.
It's fine.
I don't think I'll have a level three.
He's dead.
It's a perfect KO.
Aside, aside from the fact that you missed all of the DIs,
the Antires were good.
No, the Antires were good.
You did the EX Fireball, Drive.
brush you know you did the cancel the the auto heavy cancel
into a fireball yeah yeah see it's overall a lot of stuff
was was good there we we just got to get that we got we got
to get that one thing but you know we'll work on the one
thing it's gonna work there you go okay getting a little
spicy i mean that's a very creative way like i'm glad you're
experimenting with dry brush at all Which is cool.
I'm proud of you.
But also, you're very close to Burnout now because of it.
Oh, no.
But you didn't go into Burnout, though.
So that's a W right there.
Oh, I'm now.
Yeah, you're now in Burnout.
It's alright.
Okay.
Nice.
You are...
Hypothetically, you would be ready for the Ingrid matches.
I mean, you're not gonna play it, but...
Oh, I want it to do too.
What?
Okay.
I mean, at least I'll take it, sure.
At least you remember that the button exists.
Okay.
All right.
I'll take it.
That's good, that's good.
What is your plan?
That's right.
Oh, I...
Um...
So, remember when I say you shouldn't drive rush off of the
auto plus square, you know?
Yeah.
It doesn't do much damage and, um...
You...
You need to not burn out.
We need to work on not burning out.
We need to work on, you know, punishing the eyes.
Those are the two things.
It's fine.
I have burnt.
Okay.
okay oh nice reactions too it's looking good what oh oh yeah
that goes full screen so she has level three be careful what
yeah she has if he has if she has level three you can't
freely throw fans anymore oh yeah oh okay nice
oh oh hey um i was gonna do an overhead though you saw that
you saw that yeah yeah yeah no i saw the startup of it the
overhead did come out she just hit you out of it i believe
you i like i'm gonna burn out i'm gonna burn out i'm gonna
burn out i'm gonna burn out i mean i'm gonna burn out that's
that's that's fine
nice there you go wait what do i do for that i don't what if
they jump yeah you just do forward plus special again this
is the you do the entire okay it works on neutral jumps too
wait what's for it special it's it's the the antire you've
been using this entire time wait when they jump i okay wait
wait i'm confused the same way they jump forward at you if
they neutral jump you can still antire them with the same
button oh my god you you know what i mean like no okay i'll
i'll show you okay it's it's the same concept it's what
you've been doing this whole time it's just the entire all
they're doing is neutral jumping you know oh oh no I'm here
now oh I did not mean to do that I did not mean to do that
it's okay I'm on I'm not in the corner though at least all
right oh
Oh god.
It's alright.
Oh my god.
She's predicting me.
So every now and then, remember like if you have a good
guess, you want to jump?
What?
The fuck?
Like if you guess when she's going to fireball, sometimes
the best to just jump at her, you know?
Oh my god!
Chugged me!
oh my gosh she just keeps grabbing me
okay um oh i i did not want to press twice but it did for me
just remember that you did miss another di reaction
opportunity ah out the best that you can do there is just
due to a super oh if if she lets me survive there you go oh
i didn't think she would block that but i guess she does
oh no no no
oh Oh, hey, she DI'd.
Yeah, she did.
She did DI again.
We just, we just, we just need, we just need one of those,
you know, like we really need one of those.
It'll eventually work, right?
I think so.
I think you'll get it eventually.
I'm worried about that level three ever since you talked to
me about it.
Yeah, there you go.
Just block it.
Yeah.
Perfect.
That's good.
And now she has no meter.
Yeah, she does it!
What you gotta do!
Oh!
Yeah, see there you can just press forward and special the
same way, you know what I mean?
It's forward plus triangle, that thing.
If they neutral jump there, it's gonna hit.
Uh, what the f- I've never seen that move before.
um i mean you were you were dangerously close to treading
the passion line um but um i'll show you what i mean after
oh my god oh no she she got me she got me she's got me oh
nice you should uh okay what i want you to do what i want
you to do okay well i didn't have a time what i was going
what to do well i wasn't so wait pause the queue for a
second pause the queue don't don't start up yet don't start
oh no no okay pause it pause it i don't know if i can dive
no it's it's pause it's pause it's pause okay all right so
so stop that for a second so um let me uh let me let me
invite you to train mode again real quick again um because
there is there's two things um sue
so the problem that you were having um is that I guess they
would neutral jump and you didn't know how to deal with it
like when they would try when they would throw or when you
would try to throw so um I'll just show you what I mean
uh go into the training slot at the bottom them all right so
what i want you to do is i want you to hold up when i dash
and throw you okay so
so just hold up oh you can do the same thing that's what i
was saying you just okay that's also confused i'm like all
you have to do is just press forward and special the same
way so confused no the same way you antire as if someone was
jump at you normally like it beats people and air so if you
do that it still beats people whether they neutral jump or
back jump or something in the corner you know what I'm
saying another small thing that I want you to get used to in
general this will this will slightly help your burnout
problem here yeah is that here let me take away some of this
meter is just throw fans at me I want you to just get used
to using this to stop, like, to parry fireballs.
Okay.
Yeah, so get used to parrying fireballs.
You see it, you see your meter go back up, you know what I
mean?
Instead, just block it again, so just hold down back.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
You see how you're losing meter no matter what?
However, if you're parrying instead...
you see how you're at the same the same bar yeah so you want
to use parry so even more so i'll show you a little a little
so just hold it you see how your meter is going up yeah
because you're not the amount of time it takes you to so
when you use parry it takes about half a bar okay if you
just hold it so if you know they're gonna throw multiple
fires at fireballs at you if you just
keeping it at the same spot.
So get used to, at least at the bare minimum, get used to
just parrying fireball just a little bit.
This will probably help you specifically when you have to
play against like Chun-Li of the three characters you're
playing against.
This will probably help you a little bit more when you have
to play against Chun-Li.
But yeah, other than that, you know, just make sure that you
can still, you can still anti-or neutral jumps.
That was an issue for you.
so just make sure you remember that um and also remember
this button you haven't really used this yet today okay all
right it's a good button it is a great button so that
is also very good remember that don't don't forget that part
either yeah that's great okay i'll try
this i believe i believe i believe in feisty whoa i believe
if i see if i see isn't gonna need help and you can help her
is she after me for coaching no oh no no i don't think so oh
okay i thought that's what you meant no no she's so good at
this game i believe in her yeah no she's she's she's gonna
do i'm sure she's gonna do great and i think you know her
teammates are also gonna do great should they put the work
in i put in so much work you cannot say that i played in
korea i i didn't say you wouldn't or you haven't put in the
work but i'm saying that you should put in some more in the
training room you know training room uh every day okay one
you're gonna see this you're gonna see this on the
tournament day i'm gonna need to see a counter di i'm gonna
need to see a counter di on tournament day you're gonna see
this though yeah you got you got plenty of time to figure it
out um just make sure you do that um and if you have to if
you want to train it just do do the c viper training yeah do
the c viper thing okay okay we can do this we can i think so
we can do this i believe in us i'll do this and i'll do this
and i'll do this and i'll do this and that's everything yeah
all that all that is great and i think you should make sure
you do that yeah and make sure you do uh wait what's the
other thing oh yeah the counter di yeah that's the main
thing we need to work on that yeah there you go we've been
trying for two weeks
do the c viper recording do the c viper recording please
please do the c viper recording i've absorbed everything but
we've been trying to do this and when you play a match When
you play a match, I need you to hit a counter hit DI.
You need to hit one eventually.
Okay, okay.
That needs to be your mission.
Our goal is to walk at one.
Win or loss.
No matter if you end up in silver again, you need to hit
one.
Okay, I believe.
It can't be that hard.
You'll get it.
When it clicks, it'll click.
When it clicks.
Whenever it clicks, it'll click.
yeah anti-air error is easier than counter di it is easier i
think anti-air is so much easier than counter di i think
it's where you have the button i think the button placement
is just closer yeah and i think also your finger is always
on special anyway because you're chucking fans all the time
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah i get it the positioning
of that button is going to because, you know, you don't have
it in a normal spot or yeah.
You can't also do it normally how you would in classic where
you just press heavy punch and heavy kick, which might be a
bit more intuitive for some other people as well.
It's in an awkward spot.
If you play on leverless, I think you play on.
Yeah, I play on leverless, yeah.
Yeah, so it's gonna be an awkward spot for you, but just get
used to it and yeah, you'll be in a good, If you could just
get that part, you got the antires.
Yeah, I got the antires.
We got this part down.
Yeah, we just need some...
This part.
Yeah, we just need some DIs to...
Yeah.
Some counter DIs, not just regular DIs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe in us.
You know what?
Mickey's gonna see me counter DIs so much.
Is he?
He's gonna see me counter DIs guy and then he won't be
disappointed in me
oh man all right well yeah all right well i think i have uh
oh yeah i have given you homework all right my homework is
this um it's that but the counter but the counter but the
counter Yeah.
Just get, yeah.
Just get used to that with Viper.
Okay.
I think you will be in a great place.
I think everything else you pick up on very fast is just
this one thing.
It's just this one.
It's so far from my fingers.
It's like, it's like, it's like the one, the finger next to
the pinky finger.
And I have to like stretch it.
And it's, it's like a waste of my time.
Well, I mean, it's not, it's not really a waste.
know but it's just it's just really inconvenient it's so
inconvenient yeah i mean so a lot of us have like extra two
buttons i have them on my stick now actually okay so my di
button is like where you're so you if you play on leverless
where your jump button is that's my di button oh yeah yeah
no guys i can't refine it because then the other buttons are
even further away.
Yeah, you need all the other buttons.
This is a problem that I've had with actual with the modern,
actually.
Just something you have to just something you have to get
used to, I think.
Yeah, you'll get it.
Yeah, I think I can do it.
I can do this.
Alright.
Let's watch me play two more ring games.
Let's go.
we can watch you play two more well even my dog wants to
watch me yeah two more we're good all right um in in modern
you need to do uh i'm pretty sure you needed to use a di
button specifically um sorry someone was asking if you can
do uh the manual input the manual input for like classic
would be like heavy punch and heavy kick i believe in modern
you actually need to use the it's a button yeah yeah same
thing with parry i've had this issue when i was playing um
when i was playing modern shun for a little bit uh i had i
had to figure out how i was gonna have that work there's a
lot of like that this is partially the downside to modern um
there are a lot of buttons that you have to have and uh you
know there's gonna be some buttons that are gonna be pretty
inconvenient even though the uh you know the objective of it
itself is to be a bit more intuitive and it is in a lot of
ways in fact it's it's great but this is that small part
where it can you know it's a little bit difficult to work
around oh no you started the fight first oh yeah it's really
bad yeah this connection is spicy i i i will say i pressed
it i did press it i need you to know i pressed it i yeah i
mean i'm not gonna i'm not gonna fault you in this match i
mean you're playing in two frames of delay and five frames
of rollback on wi-fi you know so oh wait he's on wi-fi i
just noticed he is on wi-fi so i'll give you the benefit
okay yeah exactly yes this one's all right you're fine just
just just get out of here as fast as possible you need to oh
my god i did press it i did press it i just you know you
look look okay honestly in my head that counts That counts.
That counts.
Yeah, he missed his.
That's on him.
But you did react and die.
Yeah.
What?
I pressed buttons.
If you pressed anything, but auto plus square, you're going
to lose here.
Oh, I did.
Okay.
He likes to.
What?
Okay.
One time.
I mean, honestly, I don't...
I'm not going to...
to hold it against you here okay yeah no this guy just this
the wi-fi ate my input yeah i mean you could go with that if
that's your that's your excuse here yeah yeah honestly it's
it's valid we can all see the two frames of delay yeah
exactly guys okay i'll change the connection because um
maybe so what you can do is you can set it to confirm so
that you can actually I alt tab when I oh I all tab when I
queue up so then I when so I don't have to tab back in and
confirm you know I just hear like you're in a game and I'm
like I shouldn't you shouldn't be you be doing the Viper
drills while you're waiting for matches instead oh
yeah oh my gosh I'm I pressed the wrong button because I'm
on the different side again we got that we got to work on
this side what ah hmm that one was a doable just gonna hit
there you go
Oh, no.
My brain has to swap in real time.
You know, you should put yourself on two players' eye versus
the V rivals.
She ignored me when I said that.
It's the first time I've ever heard her not talk.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
Please.
Passion.
Yeah!
Perfect!
I got perfect, though.
I got perfect.
He did, yeah.
It was perfect.
I'm just locked in, you know?
Too locked in.
A little too locked in, but you're doing great.
Oh!
It's because she...
He was above me.
Oh, hey.
All right.
No.
I thought he was going to try and grab.
But it's okay.
I won.
He did win.
Good job.
I'm going to leave because I was his rank up game.
All right.
Cool.
Hey.
All right.
Well, good job out there today.
No, that makes him, I know that pissed him off.
I ended his streak and it was his rank up game too.
But you missed all of your DIs, so that's what you got to
focus on.
Not all of them.
I did hit the one with Rashid.
It's just, he was on Wi-Fi, you know?
He was on Wi-Fi yet.
We need to get, you know, I don't know, that whole game is,
that one didn't happen, but we need a real one.
We need to happen in a real game where you do a count.
this one this next game this next game you're watch this
we're playing another one like watch what last one last one
and now put it at limited all right watch this watch this
shine you're gonna see it right here also we're like one
more passionate game away from just getting getting kicked
out of here one last run all right right oh no it's okay
it's a kuma all right all right here we go and don't don't
don't don't lock in that much please
oh my gosh i was trying to counter but
we just yeah this is what akuma players will do is what they
do you miss one I know I know we gotta we gotta get those we
gotta get those we gotta get those I need I need just one I
was promised that you would show me one in this game and I
haven't seen it it's gonna be here I need to see my god now
I can't do it because I because I had the pressure It's just
the pressure is getting to me.
Look, now I can't do it.
Now I can't do it.
Yeah, you're almost going to be able to do it.
Okay, now you can.
Just like, you know, just...
Oh, he countered me?
No, he countered me!
I thought I was countering him.
You were not, but even if you did, it wouldn't have been our
reaction.
have counted that oh there's another one you missed it okay
but like that one was unpredictable we got to get those
people people do them you know i mean like that's the point
it's supposed to be unpredictable you got you got to react
there there okay but like that didn't that didn't hit me
that one that one is not the situation i'm talking about
like i i even he didn't do a di you know
I thought I did bait this is not fun sorry okay what you can
do here so don't don't do another fan don't do another fan
what I want you to do do back plus triangle plus circle but
not immediately wait wait wait wait wait wait wait what the
I'm confused I was trying to back with circle plus triangle
is her level two so when he does a fireball which will just
do that just react to it oh um i let go of back i let go of
back yeah so well the thing is the thing is also is that you
want to wait for him to throw the fireball react to it and
then do yeah and then do that but you need the you need the
level one power up the little stocks at the next to your bar
it shows how many you got left yeah like that's this yeah
that's what i'm trying to get at so but you know it's fine
it's you know all right all right now this is the last one i
forgot to quit yeah okay um yeah all right um this one is
the last one all right you got you got one more chance and
then we're hitting viper drills
um okay oh thank you i i i was gonna pause and press i i was
spamming it i was spamming it yeah so the problem is that
your crouch light kick is not cancelable so maybe you would
have gotten it but i don't know given the history though i
unfortunately can't you know i can't give you the benefit of
the doubt on that that you did press it or not i have no
idea you may have you can watch the replay and then you see
the buttons being spammed yeah i'm not gonna watch the
replay i just gonna need you to see i'm just gonna need to
see you do it
oh chip damage Yeah.
That's what happens when you burn out.
Oh, I thought he was going to block it more.
Oh, we got one.
We got one.
I told you what's going to happen.
I told.
Oh, and then.
Oh, I didn't think he was going to do another one.
I will sit.
I didn't, I didn't think he was going to do another one.
I didn't.
Honestly, I'll take.
Oh, I'll take.
I'll take what I can get.
I didn't think he was going to do another one, though.
I really didn't think.
I didn't think he was going to do another one.
Oh, what the?
Oh, my God.
You know, even if we lose, just remember, I did.
What?
Oh, my God.
Are you stupid?
Okay.
All right.
but you got it you got one you got one you got one yeah we
could use a little bit more work but that is we got the
county yeah yeah it's progress that's the crap all right we
did it we did it progress is always a good thing no matter
how look we got a counter di it's not even the first of two
weeks guys it's the first in the coaching session i think
it's the first one with intention with no no no i've had
intentional counting yes before i don't know if they've been
intentional we did it that was good that was good we did it
we i think i think you were able to do a lot of things yeah
to do previously yeah um now you're comfortably in pla you'd
have to really like mess this one up you know i'm i'm gonna
message you tomorrow and you gotta be in cold can happen it
can't happen you want me to you want me to grind that's the
consequences of grinding i mean you'll you'll be a better
player for it for sure you gotta you gotta grind exactly
thank you for the coaching session no problem good job out
there today uh thank you i worked really hard yeah no that
was that was good that was good i think i think that was
good and we we finally got a counter di at the end of it
yeah see it took a while but we made it we did it you were
like we're never gonna get one but we did get one in the end
we got one and it was against alex which is also what coney
is playing so it's like yeah it's like i counter di coney um
well I mean, maybe we should work on actually counter DI and
Kony himself and, you know, we'll work on getting there.
Yeah, yeah, but like it's almost, it's like a practice Kony.
I literally got a practice Kony off.
Yeah, a little bit, but like also he did like four or five
of them.
So, you know, like practice Kony is kind of cooking you
right now.
Yeah, but like that's why he's practiced.
He's not cooking me in the tournament.
That's, that's, that's okay.
it's not a tournament all right well all right ggs ggs all
right good job thank you for the coaching session all right
no problem make sure you do the viper drills please yeah
please i will try my best please please do them please i beg
it's just the rate games go by so fast like i get a game in
so fast like i have to redo it restart the drills every time
yeah i mean maybe you should pause it and just do the drills
then you know well dead silence
it's like crazy talk you know i feel like that's it's just
like i don't understand like what do you mean like anyway
ggs good luck with your good luck with i guess other
practice session yeah yeah all right well all right thank
you again sean all right take it easy all right bye bye all
right well i think that was really productive
I think, you know what, I, I think it was very productive.
Yo, I'll do one more game, and then we'll, we'll do some
customs with dragons.
We'll do, we'll do one more game, and then, like, we'll do,
like, a little bit of customs.
So, guys, get your, you can only play Viper, Viper, Alex, or
Chun-Li.
I will not fight anything else.
I'll, oh, look at that.
That's a good practice right there.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
I might be in burnout, guys.
Not yet!
Not!
Now I am.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's five.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was an intentional burnout.
Okay.
All right.
No!
Oh, my.
I got okay oh this is not what I wanted to do but that's
okay that's okay he has to get whoa it's okay he has to get
close to me oh god it's okay oh
that's not good that's not good yeah it's all right all
right now all right okay see how would i counter di if he
does a di good enough good enough all right all right let's
create a room i will only fight the We'll put a training,
dude, for people.
Alright.
I will...
No, I didn't purposely want and done them.
I just...
The thing is, I was just trying to create...
I said one match, and I'm going to create a custom room,
guys.
Alright.
I will only play against the following characters.
Alex, Viper, and...
Lee.
Those are the only characters I will play against.
I will not fight anyone else.
This guy's gonna beat my ass because he's... Also, I am on
the left side.
I will win the coin flip.
I...
Guys, I will win the coin flip.
Trust me.
Alright.
Round one, fight.
Oh my god.
You bitch.
You're doing, you're only doing, you can't do this to me.
You can't counter DI me.
That's counterproductive to my learning.
How am I supposed to learn?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
But like, what is that move?
What is that move?
I swear nobody has the DLC pass for Viper.
Count me I might me right now.
Count me I mean right now.
Do it.
You know you want to.
You know you want to counter D.
That's right.
That's Because I don't know if Capcom's watching.
Oh, oh, your grandmaster!
Your grandmaster!
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I saw your rank.
Doesn't matter if that's not their main.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if that's not their main, guys.
They still have the mechanics down.
It doesn't matter.
I'm ready Look, that was a Grandmaster And I took a round
off So I take those I take those
I take it
Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god Hey, I'm burnt out.
Oh my god, I thought he was gonna do a...
Oh my god!
That's right, I'm no longer...
No, I just got out of the corner!
That's right, I'm no longer in the corner.
That's right.
No, that was my grab.
That was supposed to be my grab.
That was...
Oh, please tell me I...
Yes!
Get out of here!
You might have de-eyed me, but you're the one that lost.
That's goddamn right.
Nobody...
Put Stokey in the corner, except Stokey yourself.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
Did I swear during the tournament?
I don't remember.
I don't know if I'm allowed to anymore.
Oh my god.
That was an accident.
Oh no.
No.
Please
Yeah, okay, give me a sec
Okay Okay, I might have guys I might burnt out again.
I might have burnt out again, but like Oh my god I don't
know it worked I've never seen that move in my life Never
seen that move in my life, but it worked what the what oh
oh my
god oh
my god I try to beat it too
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, what the fuck?
Hello.
I have burnt out yet again, ma'am.
No!
Oh my god, I got out, I got out, I got out.
I got out, I won!
I won!
I got out, I got out, I got out.
I got out.
How did they mess up?
I know, right?
How could they have messed up?
Not me.
No!
Yes!
I am yes!
Guys, do you guys Did I see that?
I countered DI!
Did you guys see that though?
Okay.
That's right.
What?
Oh no.
Yes!
Oh!
Yeah.
Okay.
Why aren't you countering DIing it?
Huh?
Oh my gosh, whoops Oh
shit Oh shit.
Oh shit.
Oh My guy.
Oh my god Oh my god.
Okay.
Get out of here, Alan!
Get out of here!
Oh no!
There we go.
Alright, we're doing it.
We're slowly, we're slowly figuring it out.
We're slowly...
Alright, I'm gonna do two more and then I'm gonna call it
here.
I just need you guys to know I have not eaten lunch at all.
I'm Wait, this is training stupid.
This is how do I get out of training?
We're training
How do I get out?
All right, we're in training.
All right, I'll get out of here give it some people other
chance Alan get out give other people a chance to fight me
That's right.
The man!
Alright, oh, a Chun Li.
That's different.
Alright.
Now we have a Chun Li to fight.
Hey, we're the same rank.
Hey, I... I burnt out?
It's five.
Only five.
Oh, I did.
I put myself in the corner.
It doesn't matter.
Yes!
Why can't my flat players be...
I'm sorry.
You are a good player.
Hey, I
burnt out.
Oh, shit.
Hey, no, no, no, no.
He is flat.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I did not mean that.
Oh, you dropped your combo.
I did mean all of that.
That's a guy.
God damn, right?
You know what, I'll humor you on the right side.
I'll humor you.
I'll...
If only my plat players were just like...
My prank players were just like that.
Alright.
No, I...
Tree Fighter makes me so angry.
It makes me so angry.
I hate this side
Oh my god It's because I'm on this goddamn side Okay, thank
you I really appreciate that How am I gonna die if you get
me out of
burn Dragoo is just supposed to be helping me
Thank you.
That was helpful.
I will say it.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
It's fine!
Burn up was on purpose!
Burn up is on purpose!
There!
See?
C, C
All right
Look, I know I could have countered the eye.
I know I could have I know I could have countered, but no
No, not the side not
No Yeah,
it's a countered the eye I
Couldn't win a shit.
Okay, I'll do one more.
All right.
I'll do it this time.
This is the last one for real and then I got eat I gotta eat
Should have had countered the eye How am I supposed to
counter the eye?
you if you won't let me
No, that was my fist though No It's not fair
Oh, no
Yeah!
There we go.
All right.
That's right.
Come on.
No!
Come on!
When I say D.I.
Me, I meant when I tell you to.
It's not fair.
This is not fair.
This is absolutely fair.
not fair.
This is...
You ass.
Yeah, but I didn't mean now.
I pressed it.
I need you to know I did press it.
Oh my god.
I swear to God I'm pressing it, guys.
I swear to God.
I swear I swear to God.
I am absolutely pressing it.
I am absolutely pressing D.I.
I swear.
I did it.
Yes, who has a level three for once?
There we go.
Oh.
Oh, guess who blocks this?
Bitch, that's right.
It's me.
That's right.
Yes.
All right, I'm done, guys.
GG's.
I might have another, I might do another custom lobby later
tonight.
do need it i will do another custom lobby later tonight guys
but thank you all for the practice for the practice this
this might have been the most i've ever practiced for a
street fighter i will say that i will my record is not great
i will tell you guys right now my my is not the uh let's see
guys all.
It's getting there.
Not as much as Zangief yet.
Not as much as Zangief.
But definitely the most I've struggled.
No, actually Zangief I struggled so hard.
I think I was hard stuck silver or gold.
I don't remember.
I didn't lose to a gold two.
I beat them.
I was trying new things out.
Guys.
But But it's more practice than I've done on Honda It's for
sure more practice than I've done on Honda Oh Anyway well
I've been I'm have I'm I'm existing in Street Fighter Yeah
hey guys i'm gonna head off now hope you guys enjoyed
watching today's practice coaching session we will have
another coaching session tomorrow last one as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing are you still for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye but yes i do have a street fighter six
tournament on on thursday that's why i've been practicing
guys i do have that's that's I've been trying.
I swear, God, I've been trying so hard.
I swear.
I, I, this is the most combos you've ever seen me done,
guys.
I'm actually doing combos right now.
I'm like, I'm slowly progressing.
I've never done combos before, but I'm actually doing combos
now.
Anyway, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.